I know you guys heard of this ready
Michael Rapaport essentially running
over to stop someone from opening an
airplane door that would be during the
flight that would be Mike don't know
about this no this is true that's true
because there's witnesses this is I'm
saying I didn't I didn't hear about oh
yeah yeah but how ever did you know this
that you can't open it during flight
what do you you can't open them or so
it's impossible they'll say yeah that
that you might wanna look that up Jim
but that's what I was told by someone
who flies free United because I went
when I was on my flight I said something
to the lady I went oh how about that
crazy person try or she bribes because
how about the crazy British I open the
emergency door I go I know my boy
stopped them that's a good friend of
mine my crap porn she goes yeah up she
is but in fire away at it cuz even a guy
your size can open that during
mid-flight it's impossible just why
would they make it that easy to do you'd
kill the whole [ __ ] plane yeah she
was it's impossible to do mid-flight
yeah there was a defensive end I played
in the NFL for a long time who try to do
it he got up and he had a psychotic
incident he's like six foot you know
seven and he was huge and he tried to
open nobody and everybody was like you
got this giant who's having a psycho
psychotic in and and he couldn't the
planes are gonna put that much faith in
a humanity that people aren't gonna open
that [ __ ] up otherwise Isis so what it
might do a low you got him to stop the
guy I'm not sure what exactly Mike do oh
so it says it's like a thousand pounds
to pull it so just the the pressure
alone it's pretty much impossible but
there's got to be tons of locks of stuff
yeah there's lots and safety so you
can't just open it like a [ __ ]
though a guy was trying to open it he's
thinking it was a bathroom door but no
one knew at this at the time so Michael
ran up to him and said this what the
[ __ ] are you doing and the guy was like
genuinely confused
so after they interviewed room later on
he's just a guy I'm guessing he's
probably like a foreigner maybe an Asian
dude or something that had just no idea
where the oh so he wasn't like gay Mike
was like Moo Scott right now I'm like
[ __ ] them up knows what the [ __ ] you do
yeah and the guys like oh I didn't know
its rapport I'm out here you know
[ __ ] incident on the plane hey baby
fake rock he's with the big three guys
yeah we're the big three guys the
basketball Baron Davis hasn't made that
face since he bangs on CareLink oh he
had to Kirilenko face the Kirilenko
Dunphy baby we trying to get you in the
Expendables man but your reaction time
your reaction you know baby could be an
action star I thought big baby got
arrested from all that marijuana all
right this is I think Variety reported
that Johnny Depp uses a earpiece he pays
a audio engineer to feed him his lines
through an earpiece because he's a
contra memorize all the lines
that's a report by variety however
Johnny Depp says the reason to use it is
because he does this this is his quote
I've got bagpipes a baby crying and
bombs going off over the ear piece he
says it creates truth so when he's in a
scene where he wants to look you know
like he's really focused or whatever he
has this stuff playing in his ear to get
him to that moment to them yeah he's
right I don't give a [ __ ] what he
chooses Johnny oh he's only been doing
it for effort at one of the highest
levels of all time and even if he did
some phenom lines okay for you guys
Hayden put that earpiece in and we'll
feature the same line yeah exactly you
pull this off exactly let me see you do
[ __ ] Edward Scissorhands with that
thing in your incorrect [ __ ] off correct
correct
let me see whatever your medicine you do
Willy Wonka and [ __ ] play that guy in
width of ear peon that's [ __ ] schmuck
that's right that's exactly right like
it doesn't matter like you you've done
some acting you have an appreciation of
how hard like
I don't know you guys memorize lines
it's not about lines that's a good
example it's more about what he said
it's about the behavior it's about the
character it's about your your your the
emotion behind the lines right again I
can say something and and you don't feel
it I can see that I can just look at you
and you feel some time memorized in an
hour and 20 of stand up Jim that's what
I'm saying well you you guys develop
that you guys created those lines yeah
I'm saying when you guys do acting stuff
I don't know hi guys memorize these
because what is the intention behind the
line what are you doing and then you
also get the script for a while so you
keep going over you that's tribute yeah
and you run lines before hand that'll do
it - I'll do it maybe you need a little
more scare like your lights trying to
give you a little heads up I'm the red
spotted leopard dude you're the red owl
you're the big red game no I'm there on
the spotted owl I'm just I'm the red
spot
I'm ready pop you're 51 you know my
psoriasis I'm on the spotted red red
spots
what has red spots in the wild Oh
reverse no no I got to be a I'd like to
spotted leopard something like the red
the red leopard no no that sounds too
cool
what has red spots red spots what common
animal that's your kid red spots I don't
know man well red spotted animal I'm
sure there's some fish outside Speedy's
request writer springer spaniel dogs
large spotted knew it sometimes you'll
be a new man chill I said I knew how
much you the big gay knew what is that
what do you mean they're lizards
they're like wet lizard oh yeah I used
to have a lute there's a there's a
[ __ ] out you're right you said frogs
yeah that's a that's one of those
poisonous products poisonous tree frog
I'm a Panama frogged yeah the Panama I'm
a man frog the man from I'm the man
man frog Panama Panama hug man frog from
Panama yeah you ladies like a 51 year
old with two kids a wife and red spots
on his body kid it called me the
psoriasis kid do you that's a
weird-looking ladybug person I'll tell
you what you don't do my son goes this
summer camp place and they have all the
whole thing where kids can stick their
hands and with the ladybugs and latex
over their hands well they're too
and what they do is when you do they go
ah when they brought it out I feel like
that's a bad idea with these kids
because it's gonna took on my son's hand
and those big old mitts that he has
probably to shut pretty tight and hard
than it now almost kids just the real
gentle they're like I don't think so
some little boy goes ah knocks him off
like all of them fall out my god and I'm
like obviously me good man my son's like
ah I love me he's like this body issue
was amazing but being on one of their
covers is so awesome unreal and honestly
what the [ __ ] he's got a great sense of
humor
that's a great shot good for him
question is was he wearing a sock on his
three-piece set I don't know I've done
nude scenes and you wear a little
hammock and there's a string right up
your ship sure they do for that yeah and
you got a little tiny rubber band around
your waist weird I did it when I done it
not TV yeah a movie called oh hi I met
Sarah Marshall I've done it a couple
things where I had to wrestle a larger
black man did you see that movie oh I
had to wrestle oh so you were in prison
sir Marsh sure was everybody I did but I
know I know what you said for good sir
marginal and now I go wow I've seen that
one my favorite movies jingles mine to
spoof what was it called the guy who had
knocked up Sarah Marshall and forgot to
tell her about it
super two-year-old yeah but I had to
wrestle or whatever sensor module yeah I
had the rest a large black man naked
basically and it was and then he put his
ass in my face and I went hepatitis
there's a picture of me wrestling and I
also jerk off and they shoot large
amounts of silicone at the camera it's
such a ridiculous movie I couldn't watch
I saw it I was like it's the it's the
comes on in the silliest movie of all
time but a lot of people have seen it
mmm all right so this is actually where
I live pretty much in front of where I
live this homeless crazy Skid Row dish
it's so true though flying kick oh yeah
this looks super impressive some
homeless guy had a two-by-four or
whatever with a nail in it and yeah
she hit someone in the face bad so that
guy got jacked so this other Good
Samaritan ran over and gave him a
sidekick you can see it here perfect
transient so it's this guy here holding
a piece of plywood with a metal nail in
it turns out he had just used it in an
unprovoked attack on an innocent man
walking his dog he tries to use it again
on the bystander but gets knocked down
and he would then be chased and taken
down by several other good Samaritans oh
they whooped his ass
yeah his ass they slew him like exactly
right he looks like he's been shot
twenty-five times holy [ __ ]
the flying kick ensued and then
civilians beat him to deck silent flying
kick Buzzard thought he landed perfectly
it's very loosely like I would have I
jump higher but it doesn't matter not
dude how about the socks yeah they beat
the [ __ ] I'm now see handcuffed there
too that's when the cops got something I
think wow what a piece of [ __ ] similar
but I won't tell a story when you know
one of you meet somebody who's there I
have the exact same thing I came at two
girls sitting on a wall with a 2x4 and I
was talking about fighting as usual in a
group on MADtv
it was our wrap party and I I attacked
the guy and what yes I don't know we're
talking about I did say there is a
homeless guy downtown we're at a party
he was walking toward the two girls on
the bench the girl said what are you
doing
and he goes shut up [ __ ] and he was
gonna hit her with the two-by-four and I
I hit him as hard as I could in the back
of the head kick or punch with who I
punched him as hard as I could I went
home I went running up skipping and I
went do doot doot doot as I did I went
dude did you crack and I was standing
there I think with film amar and a
couple other people and it was it was
they didn't never see anything like that
and then a guy dropped the two-by-fours
goodbye for fell down and I picked it up
and I crashed it was his back and then
he got up and screamed and ran away now
he was a crazy person yeah but I did
what I had to do and
I went back and began to talk I was a
young as a young fiery young man always
thinking about those kinds of things
but I remember I was around about two
actors and they'd never really kind of
they were so shocked I think that I'd I
had done something that violent and that
quick how well how the girls react
afterwards one of them was so hot and I
was just right there didn't wide but I
did speak to her [ __ ] come on sir and
she really didn't seem to mention much
about the fact that I saved her from
getting her head caved in by a [ __ ]
two-by-four